So some of you may have noticed
it's been a little
while since I uploaded a video
here on Numberphile, and I
thought it might be fun
to explain why.
Basically I've been away.
I've been in Canada and in
the US for two events--
a conference called BrainSTEM
and the big VidCon conference
in Anaheim in California.
While I was at those events, I
had the opportunity to meet
some of the big players of
YouTube Science, including Vi
Hart, who I know a lot
of you watch already.
VI HART: And a ratio of 100
million to 141 million.
BRADY: Henry from
Minute Physics.
HENRY: All in one equation.
And it's humbly called
the standard model.
BRADY: Destin from Smarter
Every Day.
DESTIN: Hey, it's me, Destin.
Welcome to Smarter Every Day.
And today we're going
to show you some
pretty cool high speed.
Derek from Veritasium.
DEREK: The first thing I need
to do is talk about vectors.
BRADY: Michael from VSAUCE.
MICHAEL: Hey, VSAUCE,
Michael here.
BRADY: And the mysterious
CGP Grey.
CGP GREY: Cayman Islands, the
Turks and Caicos islands,
Gibraltar, the British Virgin
Islands, Akrotiri and
Dhekelia, Anguilla--
BRADY: I didn't only
meet them.
I also had a chance to film a
few quick interviews with
them, and I'll be uploading
them soon.
DESTIN: [LAUGHS]
Good Morning, Brady.
BRADY: Probably on my channel
Sixty Symbols.
So keep an eye out for that.
There's already the interview
with Henry from
Minute Physics there.
HENRY: I'll read it aloud while
I'm writing it, so I can
hear what it sounds like.
And then once it's done, I'll
print it off and bring in here
and record it.
BRADY: Now while we were at
VidCon, Destin, from Smarter
Every Day, brought along his
Phantom high-speed camera,
which is great fun.
We set it up in the main hall.
Here's me about to be
slapped in the face.
And that's a slap from
two of the most
famous hands on YouTube.
That's Minute Physics
and Vi Hart.
What a privilege that was.
Now, I had a great time.
There's lots to talk about from
it, lots of photos and
links, and I'll put them all in
the video description under
this video.
So please do have a look.
And I hope to see all those
people again soon.
Although it won't be too soon,
because I actually just put my
passport through the
washing machine.
So I think I need to send
off for another one.
But there'll be another normal
Numberphile video very soon.
DR. JAMES GRIME: Then you
list the third diagonal.
Then you take the fourth
diagonal, and the fifth.
So eventually you are going
to list every fraction.
Every faction appears on
a diagonal, and you're
going to list them.